where we left off in the last video we
had a mature
massive star a star that had started
forming a core of iron it has enormous
pressure
enormous inward pressure on this core
because as we form heavier and heavier
elements in the core the core gets
denser and denser and denser and so we
keep we keep we keep fusing more and
more elements into iron this iron core
becomes more and more massive more and
more dense it's squeezing in on itself
and so and it's it's not fusing that is
not exothermic anymore if iron were to
fuse it would not even be an exothermic
process it would require energy so it
wouldn't be even something that could be
helped to fend off this squeezing to
fend off this increasing density of the
core so we have this iron here and it
just gets more and more massive more and
more dense and so at some mass already a
reasonably high mass the only thing
that's keeping this from just completely
collapsing is we could call it electron
degeneracy pressure so let me write this
here
electron
degeneracy pressure
degeneracy and all this means is we have
all of these iron atoms we have all of
these iron atoms you know getting really
really really close to each other and
the only thing that keeps it from
collapsing at this earlier stage the
only thing that keeps it collapsing
altogether is that they have these
electrons you have these electrons and
these are being squeezed together now i
mean we're talking about
unbelievably unbelievably dense states
of matter and electron degeneracy
pressure is essentially
what it it it's saying these electrons
don't want to be in the same place at
the same time i won't go into the
quantum mechanics of it but they cannot
be squeezed into each other anymore so
that at least temporarily holds this
thing
holds this thing from keep from
collapsing even further and in the case
of a less massive star in the case of a
white dwarf that that's how a white
dwarf actually maintains its shape
because of the electron degeneracy
pressure but as as this iron core gets
even more massive more dense and we get
more and more gravitational pressure so
this is our core now even more
gravitational pressure eventually even
this electron degeneracy i guess we
could call it force or pressure this
outward pressure this thing that keeps
it from collapsing
even that gives in even that gives in
and then we have something called
electron capture
electron
capture which is essentially
which is essentially the electrons get
captured by protons in the nucleus they
start collapsing into the nucleuses it's
kind of the the it's kind of the
opposite of beta nega of beta negative
decay where you have the electrons get
captured protons get turned into
neutrons you have neutrinos being
released but you can imagine an enormous
amount of energy is also being released
so this is kind of a temper and then all
of a sudden this collapses this
collapses even more
until all you have
and all the protons are turning into
neutrons because they're capturing
electrons so then you what you would
eventually have is this entire core is
collapsing into a dense ball of neutrons
so dense
dense neutrons you can you can kind of
view them as just one
really really really really really
massive atom because it's just a dense
ball of neutrons at the same time when
this collapse happens
when this collapse happens you have an
enormous amount of energy being released
in the form of in the form of neutrinos
in the form of neutrinos did i say that
neutrons are being released no no no the
electrons are being captured by the
protons protons turning into neutrons
this dense ball of neutrons right here
and in the process neutrinos get
released these fundamental particles we
won't go to the details here but it's
enormous amount of energy
enormous amount of energy and this
actually is not really really well
understood of all of the dynamics here
because at the same time that this iron
core is undergoing through this you know
at first it kind of pauses due to the
electron degeneracy pressure and then it
finally gives in because it's so massive
and then it collapses and into this
dense ball of neutrons
but when it does it all of this energy
it's not clear how because it has to be
a lot of energy because remember this is
a massive star so you have a lot of mass
in this area over here but it's so much
energy that it causes the rest of the
star to explode outward causes the rest
of the star to explode outward and
unbelievable
in an unbelievable i guess
unbelievably bright or energetic
explosion and that's called a supernova
that's called
a supernova
super
super nova and the reason why it's
called novad comes from i believe i'm
not an expert here latin for new and the
first time people observed anova they
thought it was a new star because all of
a sudden something they didn't see
before all of a sudden it looks like a
star appeared because maybe it wasn't
bright enough for us to observe it
before but then when it when the nova
occurred
it did become bright enough so it comes
from the idea of new but a supernova is
when you have a pretty massive star's
core collapsing and that energy is being
released to explode the rest of the star
out at unbelievable velocities and just
just to kind of fathom the amount of
energy that's being released in a
supernova it can temporarily outshine an
entire galaxy and in a galaxy we're
talking about hundreds of billions of
stars or another way to think about in
that very short period of time it can
release as much energy as the sun will
in its entire lifetime so these are
unbelievably energetic events and so you
actually have the material on the from
that's not in the core being shot out of
the star at appreciable percentages of
the actual speed of light so we're
talking about things being shot out at
you know up to 10 percent
10 percent the speed of light
10 percent the speed of light that's 30
000 kilometers per second that's almost
circumnavigating the earth every second
so that's i mean these this is un
unbelievably energetic events that we're
talking about here and so if the star if
the original star was and these are
rough estimates people don't have kind
of a hard limit here the original star
original star
if the original star was nine is nine to
twenty i say approximately nine to
twenty the mat times the mass of the sun
then
it will supernova and the core will turn
into what's called a neutron star
this is a neutron
neutron star which you can imagine is
just this dense ball it's this dense
ball of neutrons and just to give you a
sense of it it'll be something you know
about maybe two times the mass of the
sun give or take one and a half to three
times the mass of the sun
so this is
one and a half to three times the mass
the mass of the sun
in
in a volume that has a diameter of about
you know on the order of tens of
kilometers so it's roughly the size of a
city
in the in a diameter of a city
so this is unbelievably dense diameter
of a city i mean we know how much larger
the sun is relative to the earth and we
know how much larger the earth is
relative to a city but this is the
something large more mass than the sun
being squeezed into the density or than
to the size of c so unbelievably dense
now if the if the original star is even
more massive if it's more than 20 times
the sun
so let me write it over here let me
scroll up
if it's if it's
greater than 20 times the sun
then even the neutron degeneracy
pressure even the pressure even even
even the the neutrons inability to
squeeze further will give up and it'll
turn into a black hole and that's i can
do many videos on that and that's
actually an open area of research still
on exactly what's going on inside of a
black hole but then you turn to a black
hole where essentially all of the mass
gets condensed into an infinitely small
and dense point so something
unbelievably hard to imagine and just to
give you a sense of it so this this will
be more mass than even three times the
mass of the sun so we're talking about
an
incredibly high amount of mass so let's
just to kind of visualize things here's
actually a remnant of a supernova this
is the crab nebula
this is right here is the crab nebula
crab nebula and it's about 6500 light
years away
light years so it's still you know from
galactus if you think of our galaxy as
being a hundred thousand light years in
diameter it's still not too far from us
on those scales it's an enormous
distance the closest star to us is four
light years away and it would take
voyager traveling at sixty thousand
kilometers an hour eighty thousand years
to get there so this is a very very
that's only four light years that's 6
500 light years but this supernova it's
believed happened a thousand years ago
right at the center and so at the center
here we should be we should have a
neutron star and this this cloud the
shock wave that you see here this is
from this is this is still the material
traveling outward from that supernova
over a thousand years
this
this shock wave or the diameter of the
sphere of material is six light years
so we could say this distance right here
is six
light years so this is an enormously big
shockwave cloud and actually we believe
that the the our our our solar system
started to form it started to condense
because of a shock wave created by a
supernova relatively near to us and and
just to answer another question that was
kind of jumping up probably in the last
video
and this is still not really really well
understood we talk about how
elements up to iron or maybe nickel can
be formed inside of the cores of massive
stars so you can imagine when the star
explodes a lot of that material is
released into the universe and so that's
why we have a lot of these materials in
our own bodies in fact we could not
exist we could not exist if if our if
these heavier elements were not formed
inside of the cores of primitive stars
stars that have supernovaed long time
ago now the question is how do these
heavier elements form how do we get all
of this other stuff on the periodic
table how do we get all these other
heavier elements and they they're formed
during the supernova itself it's so
energetic you have all sorts of
particles streaming out and streaming in
b streaming out because of the force of
the shock wave streaming in because of
the gravity that you have all sorts of
kind of mishmash of elements forming and
that's actually where you have your
heavier elements forming and because and
i'll talk more about this in future
videos most of the uranium or actually
all of the uranium on earth right now
must have been formed in some type of a
supernova explosion at least based on
our current understanding and it looks
to be about 4.6 billion years old so
given that it looks to be about 4.6
billion years old based on how fast it's
decayed and i'll do a whole video on
that that's why we think that earth that
earth was probable that our solar system
was first formed from some type of
supernova explosion because that that
that uranium would have been formed
right at about the birth of our solar
system
anyway hopefully you found that
interesting this is a fascinating
picture and if you go to wikipedia
and look up the crab nebula
keep clicking on the image and
eventually you'll get a zoomed in
picture and that's just kind of even
more mind-blowing because you can see
all the intricacy in this actual photo